you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game so let's see what we got caro-kann
and let's go for an advanced variation
and I've been playing this recently on
the white side just Knight f3 and Bishop
to e2 and just completing Kings side
development holding off on this guy for
starters this is actually a moment where
I could actually just strike at the
center with c4 I'm going to do that
instead of reinforcing deform if takes I
get to take and have a shot against the
bishop
let's do that is there some in-between
move I could actually consider a capture
here first but I think going straight in
for this is fine I'm expecting this move
no a bit surprising he's a bit
vulnerable unprotected currently Queen
a4 so the reason why I'm looking to
sharpen things up is to try and take
advantage of the fact that their king is
going to be a bit more in the center
he'll be in the center for longer and I
think this is a moment for me to maybe
play Bishop a3 hmm
certainly black wants to be in a spot to
recapture the night on takes I could
pick up the two bishops straightaway
I'm gonna go straight in for Bishop III
on castles then I can take queen a5
Bishop b4 they may just develop with
knight c6 let's see
sharp position are ready okay likely a a
good move hmm might be five will be met
with just castles I'm gonna go in for
this capture and probably just castle
next they take with the night they're
gonna still be struggling maybe I'd take
once more yeah let's do that take on d5
first it's a big moment how to recapture
exactly Queen takes I'll take with the
Queen and maybe then just play f4
although it does weaken this square I'm
gonna go for it and let's just secure a
5 and we're playing an endgame now
material is even yes I had to do a body
count just then I've lost lost track
before queenside castle Bishop g4 I'm
looking at not castling but rather King
f2 I will make him closer to the center
my castle the rook on f1 isn't really
helpful so King f2 I think is a nice
home I could go straight in for Bishop
here but
I like this first maybe you could do
that next move I really just want to
connect rooks and go from there okay
what about right now though let's let's
throw let's insert that see how they
defend okay so the Knights pinned I like
that my C pawn is controlling the knight
less then three you can take that night
out straight away hmm what about this
move here how do they ever get out of
that pin let's try this yeah they're
going to struggle some to get out of
that pin h5 I'm backing up I don't them
to work harder to get out of this pin so
I'm doing this to cut off the rooks from
seeing the world basically no
possibilities for recapture here and I'm
looking to get both my rooks on the C
and D files I think C files pretty
appealing I'm expecting b6 king b7 is
otherwise how does the King get out of
the pin that move and maybe now I go in
for this capture and I think I like this
straight away yeah I like that the rook
isn't able to capture here so I think
you have to take back and I'm looking at
a check probably with the H rook in the
event my king is checked and has to go
to the first rank my ricks would still
stay connected so I like rook H to see
one how are we doing on the clock
oh they're giving up the exchange I
guess this was too much they were too
fearful of something huh
my rook could still enter on the seventh
though they're not taking this pawn
right away maybe I should just take this
Knight out right now
yeah I'm taking the night out so my king
can approach I'm gonna try to hang on to
the center pon mm-hmm
maybe first I should give him a kick huh
Oh tough call let's do this first I'm a
bit fearful of this because it helps the
rook get active a check I'm okay if I
lose this pawn still have a something to
work with they'll be in a pin so that's
nice how to get my rooks working
effectively I want to get on the seventh
rank
okay Knight where are you headed well
let's go here occupy an open file I'm
not too concerned about losing the a
pawn
I could jump right back over to a1 or
even give a check here and I don't think
it should be much of a problem then I
can grab here but how are they getting
out of that pin could try some kind of
rook lift rook c3 to d3 or even h3 these
guys are all weak on the Queen side if I
take out their H pawn this guy is an
animal let's do this for starters
are they getting out of the pen well
that's not working runs into this tactic
probably resigned here huh yeah hmm I
wonder if they panicked some right
around the point with b6 with these
bishops working on out hmm
how to say the bishops working on
adjacent diagonals you know cutting
right into the king position hmm let's
have a look it's a sharp line for sure
very lively hmm lively position lively
position struck out as early as move six
c4 that's why sometimes you'll see
before c6 black opted for something like
the night here and the other night here
to really reinforce the d5 square so
that should see four be played there's a
quick you know should should see four be
played there's a way that black can
immediately take advantage of the d5
square by holding up I'm playing c6 if
white plays c4 then black had focused on
the d5 square this is now whole but when
black plays this early early advance c5
now this is something that doesn't have
as much reinforcement on it there isn't
a knight here just yet to secure d5 and
it turns sharp
like it played out in the game with
capture night capture and having this
tempo against the bishop we'll have a
look at it with stockfish of course but
uh yeah it gets very lively for sure
when you have this group of four pawns
all in tension
take they takes yeah I I don't know that
I don't know about this move I don't
feel inconvenience to doll I'm just
getting on with development and they
gave me the dark square Bishop which
really turned into an animal I mean both
of them did richer paid 3 is pretty
sensible just developing and I'm trying
to be inconvenient
I'm trying to inconvenience black on
CASL I could then take night takes I get
the rook so they have to do this and
that's just super ugly he's in the pen
and I could just take here straight away
so I see six seemed to be a good move I
pick up the two bishops now just take on
d5
I didn't say during the game but doing
this is saddling black at the end of the
day with an isolated d5 font so we both
have some not so healthy pawns here d5
versus c3 every every other pawn in the
position I would identify as perfectly
healthy so these are the two two dummies
I guess we could say just security five
and I'm liking my position here so it
must be somewhere in the opening stage
where black could really improve maybe
even here instead of queenside castle
because of this move which is something
in hindsight maybe I should have played
much sooner yeah I mean I opted for King
to f2 maybe they could secure their
knight position here by playing h5 but
even so it must be white who has the
advantage in large part to the bishop
pair
the primary advantage is related to the
bishop pair but taking it a step further
I prefer my king position and I like
that I have some spatial advantage with
my pawn on e5 I don't think that that
last fact about the pawn having having
some depth having some space advantage I
think that's the least positive feature
for white
but it must be something in the opening
here I think Bishop d6 is a good move
and yeah I mean he's our he's just
anchored in there and how do you uh how
do you get rid of him you know you think
I can't get out of this pin so soon on
h5 I'm just backing up maintaining the
pin and these guys are too much I don't
know maybe maybe there was a way out
here for black but it certainly
difficult I felt the need to give up the
exchange and at this point I just wanted
to take because you know the Knights are
soon to be connected I want to make sure
I could damage the whole queenside
structure just isolated ponds everywhere
now and well it really didn't even get
to this technical point where I go into
pac-man mode trying to hunt down these
isolated ponds they fell into a tactic I
mean just double check something here I
think there what was i planning to do a
riff c6 I maybe spoke too soon about
playing rook to a 1 to grab the a7 pond
because they do have Knight to c3
hitting my ruck and then maybe even 9 to
b5 I don't know it's a little bit messy
but I don't necessarily even have to go
after the a pond I could seek some rook
activity like this looking you scoop up
this pawn and advance my own pass pawn
you know maybe he could even push
through with the help of both of my
rooks so I must be somewhere in the
opening we'll have a look with the
computer in just a moment but yeah
somewhere around here black needs to
improve I think because once I have the
two bishops and we're in an endgame yeah
I think it's just too much definitely a
pull for white but okay let's have a
look at it with stockfish and see where
we can improve
okay stockfish let's see where did we
make mistakes how can we improve c5 I
know c4 is a move it's not the it's not
the best but it's sharp
what is it recommending straightaway D
take C form okay
do you take C for and then getting on
with castles it's a super open position
already a great great way ought to be
played on fast development so hmm I
guess already taking on d4 is allowing a
nice peace improvement with tempo i I
did point out in the game I thought that
this was the right way forward just to
parry the night for Bishop exchange was
that already a necessity because look at
this shift already inserting the Czech
Knight c3 takes takes and is this an
advantage that's only going to move
forward go up Bishop e3 wants to take
straight away but Bishop e3 is fine
takes take C takes d5 we're in an end
game and the material is balanced but I
have a pawn advantage
let's go a queenside castle no it
doesn't like f4 hmm I didn't think
Knight e3 was such a big deal I guess
they have to shoot it shoot for Knight
e3 and even saw theirs they're still
still something white is the preferred
side here after castles King f2 is fine
Bishop g4 fine as well yeah
King f2 is fine
how many of you would have just castled
here it's important endgame
stage he could find comfort here you
know keep him 1 1 square closer to the
action lunch once uh you know the
position is much more simplified this is
where he wants to be so it should be
king of two instead of castles and then
Bishop g4 Bishop d6 is right
b6 wants to take the knight straight
away yeah ok did that a little bit later
taking still has something still hold
some advantage what was the big fear
here I guess on takes I mean what I was
planning to do was enter on the seventh
i I didn't I didn't have this in mind
Bishop e7 I was looking at this check
King B 7 and then rook c7 is what I had
in mind and he's kind of running for his
life
one of the difficulties you experience
playing against the bishop pair is King
security you know what color square can
he really rely upon these guys always
keep him in check so to speak so still
an advantage in that line they invested
the exchange there but yeah should I
have given up the a pawn is that Alright
ro K 2 c1 is fine let's just quickly
look at Knight takes pawn rook c6 would
be good King there oh oh okay ah that's
very nice you could insert the check
with the C rook and then bring the other
rook over here and then bad news for
team black they're gonna be losing a
rook actually if the knight moves right
mate an 11 is already being called for
pigs pigs on the 7th but hmm what more
to look at just before we even get to
the endgame oh the bishop takes b1 move
it's it's already critical at this
moment right here which is what Knight
takes d4 after Knight takes d4
move seven
I guess black really has to look in at
this Bishop takes Knight move yeah
Bishop takes Knight seems to be the best
try just to get out of the harm's way
and then go in for Bishop to b4 Bishop
d2 takes takes ninety-seven no and then
it's a then it's still a fight here I
have it I have the Bishop versus Knight
type position well I have the bishop
advantage over the night I think the
bishop is an advantage over a knight in
this structure
Bishop f3 main diagonal immediately
putting pressure on d5 Knight pc6 takes
takes yep no he has a weak pawn but he
has a strong night still an interesting
position I prefer white without question
I like having a clear target tune that
of the c6 pawn and well my e5 pawn I
might even chalk up as slightly
overextended I don't see this as a a
great great asset or anything pawn on e5
but yeah as we're seeing here very a
level like position and it kicks off
with first this Bishop takes b1 move
okay well interesting game out of this
caro-kann advanced variation feel free
as usual to leave any feedback in the
comments section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you